can you believe this is my hair but has
actually been washed how am I just
forever unclean my religions not for me
I got a was pretty healthy if you don't
know now you know your life is different
now it is the end of April which means
we're all getting closer to death one
month at a time and host cuber cute pink
background some mortality is extra cute
when the backgrounds pink
eventually going back from whence we
came vagina it's not our favorite video
here are some products and things and
stuff that I have enjoyed more than
other products things and stuff this
month caveat it's very likely that I've
included some or all of these products
in a previous favorites video but my
memory is like dust in the wind
scattered let's begin first yeah say
yeah yeah say yeah yeah say yeah this is
[Music]
this is from the skincare companies
Shishido like shishito peppers but [ __ ]
sido like you don't think that girl that
lives in the apartment building across
the way saw you masturbating to her but
she see though I have this under eye
cream from Shishido that I like a lot
and this is their bio performance lift
dynamic cream ooh
this I think I got for free in some sort
of gift bag from some event but I
quickly request all the memory up in my
brain which is you know is kind of a
higher-end skincare line but I can say
that I really like a few products that
I've used from them and the packaging is
so sleek your big divots in the lid that
make it so easy to take off and oh this
is basically a cream that promises do
what every other cream you put on your
face says it does make you look better
and I think maybe this does and if it
doesn't it's got a real strong possible
effect I don't know when I put this on
in the morning and before fall asleep I
just feel like it tightens my skin and
that's all we're ever trying to achieve
in life is tight skin vagina next yeah
yeah say yeah yeah say yeah this is a
makeup brush
it's from Sephora and it's called the
airbrush powder I don't know if it's got
a number to it or
I don't know how or when I bought I have
an indoor bug zapper that said that Zach
noise was so so fun to do like ambient
noise to get used to on a regular basis
here in my household just a very zen
household is what I like to run I don't
know when or how I got this but I own
this and I love this brush I use it to
put bronze around my face like that it
feels like it's made strong and the
bristles are very soft on my skin and
for bronzer it works really well for me
see I just do that wow what a demo
access can't see I am Daniel II this is
Urban Decay all nighter makeup setting
spray I had some version of this before
but I also don't know when and how I got
this into my ownership maybe that's an
issue no we just had a personal meeting
inside our mind and it turns out it's
not an issue there's oil free paraben
free temperature control technology
there are some words for you if those
matter to you then they're on this
bottle this is spray that I put on my
face after I do my face of makeup and I
gotta say this works really amazingly to
keep your makeup in place for long
periods of time I use this when I was
over at Amsterdam recently for VidCon EU
and it really kept my makeup on my face
and in place about wearing away all day
did I just write a poem with my brain
there's a bug I used to think that this
kind of stuff was total [ __ ] I just
think it was just sort of like weird
smelling water that makeup company's
told us to spray on her faces so they
could make some extra money but I don't
use a lot of setting powder because my
skin is slightly more dry so this has
become really great next yeah okay yeah
yeah so yeah this is a candle whoa and
this is actually from Target I know last
favorites video in March I showed you a
candle that I thought was from Target it
was actually from Bath and Body Works
and so many of you so wonderfully
corrected me so immediately and I so
thank you for that but this candle is
actually from Target I don't know what
the brand is but it's bergamont wood I
think the candle I talked about last
month was also bergamot something I
don't know but this smells really great
kinda fruity but also woodsy whisk
real nice sort of gender-neutral scent
to it and I find very very pleasing also
I find the packaging very pleasing I
like not having a label out here not
only is it doing a job in that it makes
my smelling house Mellish but it also
aesthetically makes my aesthetic of my
house lush thank you candle yeah yeah
yeah yeah say yeah yeah say yeah do you
have any idea what this is
go ahead make a guess I'll wait write it
in the comments right now here we go
you're an idiot because it's a tiny
travel microphone why I've had this for
months and I don't remember if I've
talked about it what a consistent theme
in this video it did a tiny travel
microphone that was recommended to me by
my podcast director Jack Barry I
listened to episodes of not too deep on
full screen iTunes and thumbs up if you
haven't already they're really great
super fun because I travel so much we
have to record ads for the podcast and a
lot of times I'm not near my
professional microphone that I have in
my house so he recommended this travel
mic sets from this brand Shore sh ure
and it's got this little seasoned it's
got this little NP so you just plug it
into the bottom of your phone and you
download the app that is associated it's
a sure plus and you download this motive
app MOT IV and you can record
professional sounding voice over into
your phone and you can email it or share
it or save it or whatever you want to do
with it and it's just so amazingly handy
and also this little carrying case is
the cutest thing it also comes with this
cord if you need that I put the cord in
this top pocket in here and then you
just OOP OOP and it bends over like that
and then you just flip it around and
it's so convenient I think I bought this
on Amazon so you probably find it there
next yeah yes yeah I am asleep this is
hot sauce but it's not just any Cholula
hot sauce it is the Chipotle Cholula hot
sauce and clearly you can tell by the
limited amount of hot sauce that is
remaining that I love this hot sauce I
don't like spicy stuff that much but
this Chipotle hot sauce has such flavor
has new
but makes everything nice poetry it
turns out is something I do now
I've just been putting this on
everything I've been eating lately and
so I've been really loving this and I
just wanted to let you know that because
the Internet is for sharing and creating
bonds that lasts forever based on
personal connections and relatability
authenticity transparency please
subscribe okay that's it for my April
favorites video let me know what you
guys have been loving this month by
leaving a comment down below give this
video a thumbs up if you like favorites
video so I know that I should continue
making them because I watched tons of
favorites videos on YouTube that's how I
learn about things don't forget to
subscribe to this YouTube channel click
one of these buttons somewhere all
around everywhere I make videos Monday
Wednesday and Friday sometimes other
than that items oh and this is still
good till April of 2018 oh good to know
I can count on you